10 minutes cruciales pour les syndicats
ils arrivent à Matignon à 10h04 Unis le
sourire aux lèvres objectif face à
Elisabeth borne obtenir le retrait de la
réforme des retraites la réunion de
Matignon dure les syndicats sont
toujours à l'intérieur je viens de mon
chronomètre n'en est à peu près à 21
minutes 30 cette porte est encore fermée
on vient tout juste de passer les 45
minutes je regarde l'horloge 11h04 il
était 11h07 quand les Avengers de la
contestation sont sortis
[Musique]
on a la barre de l'autre côté
je suis allergique à la clim en fait et
voilà il y a des fois ça passe des fois
ça ne passe pas
et voilà ce que cela va donner au second
tour une victoire de Marine Le Pen face
à Emmanuel Macron 55 45 ça veut dire que
pour ce second tour des électeurs de
gauche préféreraient voter Le Pen que
Macron d'abord il préférait s'abstenir
demain va sortir en caisse le numéro de
Playboy avec Marlène Chapal la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'économie
solidaire et sociale elle pose habillée
pour le magazine et il donne une
interview sa collègue du gouvernement
Isabelle Rome ministre de l'Égalité
femme homme
a dénoncé le fait d'accorder une
interview à ce magazine qui est un
condensé de stéréotype sexiste prétendre
que poser dans Playboy il fera avancer
la liberté des femmes j'en doute
sérieusement la sienne peut-être celle
des autres noms sur la forme ces photos
sont très laides je veux dire en termes
photographique c'est à dire c'est des
photos de très mauvaises qualités voilà
elles sont elles sont moches c'est une
femme qui est plus jolie que ça et là
elle est vraiment pas mise en valeur et
en plus c'est tenues sont
incroyablesment ridicules c'est à dire
que en plus on en plus moi ce qui
m'interroge beaucoup c'est
le modalité de communication du
gouvernement dans le contexte
particulier où nous trouvons
parce que Madame Siepa qui va
communiquer dans Playboy le président de
la République dans gadget on dit que le
préfet de police pourrait aller ou
étaler chez Hanouna c'est quand même une
communication publique et
institutionnelle très singulière dans le
contexte français c'est mon drapeau j'ai
pas forcément envie qu'elle en fasse une
espèce de meringue pour le blanc un sac
poubelle pour le bleu parce que c'est
quand même un sac poubelle et pour le
rouge c'est on dirait tu sais les trucs
totaux tissu regardez promotion sur sur
le tissu rouge donc non tout ça c'est
ridicule bah écoutez c'est pas la peine
d'en rajouter là je pense que
il faut aller vous avez posé pour
Playboy vous aussi longtemps en plus je
n'ai pas besoin du tout
le monde s'en branle c'est le numéro
on en a vendu 7 et là il y avait
peut-être 20 euros
c'est vraiment fait la ligne de Playboy
j'ai fait la une de Playboy non mais je
vous mens jamais quand je vous dis j'ai
fait la une de Playboy c'est que j'ai
fait la une sur les huîtres
intéressantes sur votre goût de
tapisserie aussi chez vous pas aller
trop loin en fait dans dans ce que j'ai
confié quoi il y a une photo quand même
ça c'est celle que vous voyez en fait
sur la couverture elle est en pied et je
dois vous dire on fait Playboy on fait
pas Playboy après sur Playboy voici
bornes dans le oui donc la première
minute
Elisabeth borne dans Playboy c'est quand
même autre chose regardez
après Macron dans le magazine
Dupont-Moretti dans l'air tu as Malibu
vous allez me voilà me tenir la main
pour apprendre à baguer on fait un tout
petit tour de couteau sans trop appuyer
pour pas vous voilà parfait on enlève un
petit peu et puis après avec la lame du
couteau
j'arrive pas du tout ça avait l'air
facile quand c'était vous qui le faisiez
je la débague trop elle va pouvoir poser
pour Playboy après mon asperge Éric
Zemmour je n'ai pas dit de mon dernier
mot je le remercie l'heure des pros
l'émission qui ressemble à un débat en
revanche monsieur vous l'avez dit vous
allez écouter Éric Zemmour et pas
l'interrompre tout le temps parce que je
vous connaissais
une blague non pas le Figaro l'humanité
il y a les différences non pas sur les
repas je vais vous donner sur la guerre
en Ukraine par exemple je suis très
frappé il y a une
covid tout le monde a écrit la même
chose sur le covid
si en plus
j'arrête là
c'est pas sympa parce que après dans
l'émission vous dites excuse-moi j'étais
non ça c'est pas sympa c'est partisan
attend d'un geste mais l'ancien
président reste caché derrière les
vitres teintées de sa voiture depuis sa
luxeuse résidence de marago Donald Trump
dénonçant ensuite un complot politique
[Applaudissements]
même des personnes qui ne sont pas de
grands fans on dit que ce n'était pas la
bonne chose à faire c'est une insulte à
notre pays
quelques heures plus tôt à New York
Donald Trump se présentait à la barre
d'un tribunal sans personne pour lui
tenir la porte à l'entrée c'est le
président
de l'histoire qui ont aussi été arrêtés
Nelson Mandela a été arrêté et a passé
du temps en prison Jésus Jésus a été
arrêté
il y a les différences
je vais vous donner sur la guerre en
Ukraine par exemple je suis très frappé
sur le covid
si en plus vous coupez Laurent moi
franchement j'arrête là
c'est pas sympa
parce que c'est pas sympa ce qui
m'intéresse c'est votre analyse la voix
de je la connais par cœur ce qui
m'intéresse et après vous pourrez
en fait
l'un des pros l'émission qui ressemble à
un débat